we've been following this everybody in
our business has been following this
over the past week
spotify is in a heated battle they're
embroiled in a major controversy
because they are hosting
right now exclusively
the biggest podcast in the world
kill tony
and
tony hinchcliffe if you remember had an
incident
a few months ago where he's had a few
choice words for an asian opener of his
as a joke as a bit
and he's become one of the biggest media
stories in the world neil young and joni
mitchell have pulled their music off
spotify because they continue to host
kill tony the biggest and most
influential podcast in the world
tony hinchcliffe has uploaded videos to
his
instagram trying to clarify some of his
positions and uh apologizing for past
use of the n-word
and spotify the ceo daniel eck has said
we are standing behind tony hinchcliffe
and kill tony
why are you laughing
what why i mean it's a serious situation
no i know i'm i'll be i'll be serious i
don't know why you're laughing
i thought it was something totally
different what do you think you were
doing a bit but what do you mean it's
different i thought that spotify was
hosting the biggest podcast in the world
which is the joe rogan experience and
joe rogan used uh some choice words on
uh in the past 12 years of the show and
they made a compilation
uh this uh musician india ari
put a compilation out on twitter she put
the compilation out yeah it's it it
doesn't look good it's him did she make
it
uh no this has been on the internet so
this has to do with joe rogan mm-hmm yes
is his show bit even big
it's up there
is it as big as kill tony uh well
spotify acquired the joe rogan
experience for like a hundred million
dollars well then how much did tony
hinchcliffe get how much money do they
have
i don't think they're doing great
so you're telling me this whole
controversy is about joe rogan
and not tony hinchcliffe's uh kill tony
yeah out of context him saying the n
word repeatedly in a thirty second thank
you well i know that folks
this is a bit
i am aware of that
who knows more about that than me
i know about that
but what i did was i threw your red
herring
to keep it interesting
some of you
maybe don't know what's going on you
were led down another path but that's
not the accurate path
it is about joe rogan's show
you know
he's got powerful enemies a lot of
people dislike him
and a lot of people don't like that he
has 11 million people listening to him
and a lot of people would love him to be
de-platformed
and they want to get rid of him
and those people probably some of them
are in the white house
some of them are in congress
some of them uh have a lot of money
they're in the private sector
some of them are celebrities and
musicians
and
i believe this is somewhat coordinated
to a degree
not
i'm not overly paranoid about this
but i do believe there's some effort
there's a push
to get rid of joe
any way they can
whether whether it's he's a racist
without any evidence
he's transphobic no evidence
he's um
anti-vaxx
a little evidence
a tiny bit but not all of the vaxxes
he's had some conversations about this
particular one
and on the third dose
when israel has been dosing people there
are three or four doses in and they've
got the highest rate of omicron in the
world the idea that the vaccine has
worked
as well as we wanted it to when it comes
to preventing transmission
it is not controversial to say that it
hasn't
it certainly seems to have kept people
out of the hospital which is great but
the idea that it's worked exactly as
planned that it's gone exactly as
planned
isn't true
and joe's had a few people on the show
to uh discuss it and those episodes have
gotten millions and millions tens of
millions of views
and people are upset and neil young
and joanie mitchell
nils lofgren guitarist for the e street
band or springsteen that's right uh
india ari david crosby kind of
i don't know if he even owns his music
or not uh mary trump as well mary trump
roxanne gay
writer and podcaster roxy they've all
said let's get our music off spotify
because we want to take a stand
with
uh
the people that
these
people that wrote that letter the
scientists and the doctors who when you
look into it aren't all practicing
doctors but they wrote a letter saying
that's disadvantage
disinformation
and you're allowing it to happen you're
allowing people to speak in a room and
you're allowing other people to listen
to it jan saki who's the white house
communications director
uh do you have a clip of this witch
jen saki
literally goes they need to do more
they should go spotify needs to do more
to kick the guy off
this is the white house
press secretary
telling a private company
she
she would like
well the white house feels
it's their position
that a private company should do more to
censor
and maybe ultimately get rid of
uh a podcaster on their platform
this is uh
i guess it's somewhat unprecedented i
can't remember this happening before
it's a somewhat unique situation but i
know that you know the fcc had their
problems with howard stern and rush
limbaugh and
people always wanted them off the air
and people have always wanted everybody
off the air but this seems like a unique
situation where you can kind of
you know these musicians are in a unique
position to squeeze
spotify
and pressure spotify
uh so now there's disclaimers on
episodes that come out
um and i believe joe said he's gonna
work work to have some more
neutral or uh you know some more
opposite viewpoints
if he has somebody that's critical of
the vaccine
he's going to have somebody on the other
side of that who
is pro-vaccine he said that in his video
that he uploaded to instagram
about this he's a in a [ __ ] storm
he's in the middle of a [ __ ] storm
people are coming at him from all angles
in all directions they all have an
agenda and he's trying to navigate it
and do the best he can he's the biggest
one of the biggest entertainers
on earth now he's completely transcended
the world of comedy he's one of the most
famous people on the planet
there are
leaders of foreign countries tweeting
about this it is a national news story
for over a week
every day
the white house is weighing in
uh it is so big
and i am so incredibly jealous of this
i am so incredibly jealous of this man
and his ability to continually be in the
news
i what would i have to do
to get
anything
on this level
i mean i have chased
my whole entire [ __ ] career
the type of attention that he is getting
right now
and it's impossible for someone like me
to get
they won't even let me get big enough to
be hated and attacked
it's the one thing i've always wanted to
be threatened by the white house press
secretary to be de-platformed to have
roxanne gay pull her podcast off spotify
because of me
and i can't it doesn't happen
i want jair bolsonaro tweeting that i'm
doing the right thing
and it's it's i'm i'm in a fit of
jealous rage
at this publicity it's amazing
his ability to just keep
what should i do i'll go out and say
cancer is not real
tell me what to do to get this level of
publicity i'll say aids was good
tell me what to do
i'll say being gay is a choice
i'll say abortion uh people that have
them should be hung in a public square
what can i do
i don't even think it's that [ __ ]
controversial to say that the vaccines
didn't work that well
but that seems that's i guess the ticket
yeah that's what draws you the ire of
all of civilization
everybody gets mad and they only want to
talk about you
they only want to talk about him now
it's all about him
what about me
what about others
where is the oxygen left to discuss
my progress how well i've done the
followers we're getting the show that
we've built our massive stature on
patreon where is our shitstorm
where are our meetings with lawyers
where are our tense late night
conversations where are my apology
videos
i'm left out
[ __ ] over
again
i mean
that's my takeaway
from this
that's my frustration here
do you understand
hassan [ __ ] buys a car and it's your
trends on twitter five days
i've bought multiple cars and crashed
them
i've lived in five houses in the last
year
what's the problem